les Français qui vivent à l'étranger
sont des Français à part entière ils
font intégralement partie du destin
national
or l'expression de cet amour cheville au
corps pour la France des Français qui
vivent à l'étranger elle s'expriment de
différentes manières l'une d'entre elles
c'est le fait de disposer d'une
résidence en France parce que souvent il
y a l'amour d'un village la proximité
avec sa famille avec ses amis c'est un
port d'attache un lien avec la France et
puis c'est aussi un refuge il est
évident que pour les 1500 français
d'Ukraine pour les Français qui étaient
en Éthiopie au moment de la guerre du
Tigré actuellement au Sahel le fait de
disposer d'une résidence en France
ce n'est pas un lieu de vie légiature
c'est un refuge et donc l'idée de
définir une résidence en France pour les
Français de l'étranger comme résidence
d'attache a été la raison qui nous a
poussé avec mes collègues le président
Bruno retaillod et Christophe Rassa de
déposer en juillet de l'année dernière
une proposition de loi visant à créer le
statut de résidence d'attache pour les
Français qui vivent à l'étranger
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat et après l'examen la semaine
dernière en commission des finances du
Sénat c'est une excellente nouvelle
enfin notre proposition de loi créant
une résidence d'attache pour les
Français qui vivent à l'étranger est à
côté alors nous avons trois avancées la
première avancée c'est l'article 1 en
réalité on crée le dispositif
c'est-à-dire qu'on crée la notion
fiscale de résidence d'attache
spécifiquement pour les Français qui
vivent à l'étranger pour tous les
Français qui vivent à l'étranger et il
s'agit d'une notion fiscale nouvelle
intermédiaire entre la résidence
principale et la résidence secondaire
l'article 2 lui est un avantage fiscal
pour les Français de l'étranger au
départ évidemment nous avions souhaité
une mesure beaucoup plus large mais à
l'examen de la commission des finances
et du Sénat nous avons une version qui
est en réalité une première avancée
ne va pas aussi loin que nous l'aurions
espérer en tant qu'auteur évidemment de
cette proposition de loi mais qui
néanmoins est une mesure davantage
fiscale à l'égard des Français de
l'étranger certes limités
géographiquement au pays à risque il
s'agit néanmoins d'une avancée pour les
Français de l'étranger enfin l'article 3
que nous avons également adopté il met
la pression sur le gouvernement nous
créons une commission une commission qui
a comme objectif de devoir remettre un
rapport devant le Parlement sur la
thématique de la création de cette
résidence d'attache l'objectif final
quelle est-il c'est d'amander le projet
de loi de finance 2024 à l'automne afin
que la résidence d'attache pour les
Français de l'étranger voient enfin le
jour dès l'année prochaine
[Musique]